jan heute kommt es außerdem zu neuen
beschluss verlagen aus dem kanzleramt
rund um die korona regeln
kanzleramts chef helge braun schlägt vor
die kontaktsperre noch weiter zu
verlängern
ist das jetzt ein schritt zurück für uns
alle damit möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
meinem kollegen ralf schuler erst leiter
der bild parlamentsredaktion reif was
genau wurde denn heute beschlossen
also es lange verhandelt worden über die
feinheiten und die fortsetzung des der
korona maßnahmen sind die kontaktsperre
verlängert worden
ursprünglich sollte das bis anfang juli
bis zum 5 juli geschehen da hat man sich
dazu entschieden ist etwas kürzer zu
machen wir bis zum 29 juni und es ist
über spezielle regeln für das verhalten
in der öffentlichkeit gesprochen worden
ursprünglich gab es da aus dem
kanzleramt aber auch von einigen
bundesländern die vorstellung dass man
weiterhin eine begrenzung von treffen
auf zehn personen oder 2 haus stände wie
die formulierung ist das heißt zwei
haushalte können sich da treffen sowohl
im privaten treffen als auch in der
öffentlichkeit aufrecht erhalten sollte
die privaten treffen sind jetzt
gestrichen worden weil man gesagt hat es
ist einfach unsinn private treffen zu
limitieren irgendwie einschränken zu
wollen wenn man sie ohnehin nicht
kontrollieren kann
darum sind jetzt also treffen bis zu
zehn personen in der öffentlichkeit
möglich oder zwei ausstände das heißt
also zwei party veranstaltungen können
familien können zusammen feiern
auch in der öffentlichkeit wenn man die
entsprechende hygiene abstände einbehält
ein anderer punkt der noch mit auf der
liste stand war eine sonderregelung für
schulen und öffentliche veranstaltungen
wenn da entsprechende hygiene konzepte
vorliegen dann ist das geöffnet worden
und liegt in der zuständigkeit der
landkreise oder der kommunen die das
ausrichten rudert die regierung damit
jetzt zurück was für ein zeichen ist
dass in dieser corona zeit also sie
öffnet ganz klar weiter sie lässt die
harten regeln ein stückweit lockerer und
gibt damit das zeichen dass angesichts
der sinkenden aktiv infektion es mehr
öffentliches leben geben kann und im
prinzip folgt das dem trend den der
thüringer ministerpräsident schon
vorgegeben hat ja das an seine
landkreise übertragen und nicht mehr an
das bald geregelt das heißt wenn es
irgendwo einen infektions hotspot gibt
dann kann man weiter harte maßnahmen
fällen wenn es keine infektionen gibt
dann kann man locker lassen
eine sehr atmende lösung wie ich finde
vielen dank herr schuler für diese
erklärung